the good people of america
sure they don't know what gender they
are sure they're told that being not
racist is now being racist and all that
stuff
but something seems to be seeping
through because the polling for this
elderly man is really not going well and
they even had to cover it on nbc with
chuck todd this past weekend
by a fairly large 71 to 28 percent
margin americans say they do not have a
lot of confidence in president biden's
ability to respond to this war 57
percent say we are already at war with
russia or will be within a year a very
pessimistic view
34 percent disagree what's more 68 would
prefer mr biden make the economy his top
priority compared with just 29 percent
who want him to focus on ending this war
overall president biden's job approval
stands at just 40 percent with 55
percent disapproving this is his worst
showing yet in our polls since he became
president
you know it's bad when corporate media
mainstream media funded by pfizer media
brought to you by the drug companies
media
when they are going man this polling
looks pretty crappy we are in a lot of
trouble here let me just say this about
the war in general and whether we're at
war or not i mean we're in a proxy war
we are in a proxy war there's been no
debate about this proxy war in congress
although congress wants to you know
mitch mcconnell i want to we're going to
get we've got to arm them and 14.8
billion dollars we don't have any money
for our own stuff um but i was thinking
would it be a crazy thought
to think that perhaps guys
we have our own problems here in this
country that maybe we have problems
related to supply chain and inflation
and gas prices and health care and
foreign policy obviously but that we've
got a whole bunch of stuff that's a
problem here our education system is in
complete collapse we're watching
institutional collapse across the board
in all of our trusted institutions
perhaps we need to focus on that kind of
stuff we've got
hundreds of thousands of people pouring
through the southern border perhaps we
should be thinking about what we could
do there does that make me a putin
puppet
does that make me a russian apologist
or does it make me a decent american
who actually thinks that this government
is completely inept and should have very
little to do with our lives and if it
should have very little to do with our
lives it probably shouldn't have that
much to do with ukrainians lives or
russians lives that's not to dismiss
people being killed and displaced and
it's and it's deeply troubling and
disturbing and i look forward to all of
the good democrats welcoming ukrainian
refugees some of them nazis into their
homes you know because that's what good
people would do um so i don't think that
anything that i've said here is
unreasonable as i always say it would be
nice if the president of the united
states was capable it would be nice it
would feel great actually you know every
time i show you guys one of those
desantis videos it's like man here's a
guy in charge you know what he thinks
he's basically doing what he says he's
going to do and there's a vision there
and he's fighting he's fighting to keep
people free what is it that joe biden
and this administration are fighting for
i have literally no idea other than to
just keep the charade going right
there's no business like show business
that's where that's where we're at at
this point and the polling is just
it's just an absolute disaster so that's
the silver lining right i always try to
get you the silver lining the silver
lining is this administration's in free
fall the the woman
who is second in command kamala harris
nobody nobody thinks she's even remotely
competent so perhaps enough of us will
vote these people out when it when the
time has come perhaps enough people
especially in the midterms
will say hey we've got to get rid of the
democrats and the republicans ain't
great but they aren't all completely
insane that would be enough it's not my
words here that are crazy it's their
actions that that really is it